- You pick up any new skills
other than photography?
- I have, I am gonna tell you something.
I'm gonna admit something to you,
and again your millions of
followers and only to you guys.
I have become a really,
really adept shower cleaner.
Now I'm talking about the kind of person
that you wanna hire if you
wanna make sure you can lick
the floors of your shower before
you clean yourself in them.
My wife challenged me
with being responsible
for that part of our
weekly cleaning routine
and I took on the challenge,
and I put on the gloves,
I wear a bathing suit, and I go in there
and I'm doing it as if to prove a point.
I'm doing it as if to win
something, like whatever shower
cleaning award there is.
- Award.
- I've become really, really good.
- Like a full on toothbrush,
just getting in there?
On the ground?
- Oh Kelly, everything.
I mean, I have the brush
to get the grout off.
I have the mop, I have those gloves
that you can order on a shady website
that have like little
things coming out of them
so you can use the
gloves to clean as well.
They're like cleaning.
- You wax it on and wax it off
and another great film.
- 100%
using my Daniel Le Russo
skills to get all the grime
and crud off.
- Oh my gosh, I love you.